y aquí tenemos la receta de un pastel
grande que queremos hacer para nuestros
invitados que hoy vienen a cenar pero
esta receta es para 32 personas 32
personas pero nosotros solamente
esperamos a 16 invitados
entonces si solamente vendrán 16
invitados qué ingredientes deberíamos
tener aquí en qué cantidades debemos
agregar los ingredientes los invito a
que pause en el vídeo y lo piensen un
poco bueno lo primero que podemos decir
es que haremos un pastel más pequeño
haremos un pastel más pequeño y tal vez
ya hayan pensado en que si vamos a tener
la mitad de invitados entonces solo
necesitamos la mitad de cada ingrediente
y eso estaría bien en lugar de 8 huevos
para el pastel pequeño podemos usar 4 en
lugar de 6 tazas de harina podemos usar
solamente 3 tazas en lugar de 6 tazas de
azúcar podemos usar 3
estamos tomando la mitad de cada uno de
esos números en lugar de dos tazas de
mantequilla podemos usar una en lugar de
seis cucharaditas de bicarbonato de
sodio podemos usar tres y finalmente en
lugar de dos tazas de agua podemos usar
una taza de agua ahora esto funciona y
así es como podemos ajustar las recetas
de cocina pero hay algo muy interesante
que es muy similar en estas dos recetas
tanto la receta del pastel grande que es
para 32 personas como en la receta del
pastel pequeño y esa es la noción de la
razón o la proporción la razón o
proporción entre los ingredientes o la
razón de que tanto de un ingrediente
necesitamos para un número determinado
de invitados por ejemplo aquí podemos
ver que por cada 8 huevos necesitamos 6
tazas de harina
vamos a escribir por cada 8 huevos
tenemos 6 tazas de harina entonces la
razón que existe entre los huevos y la
harina es de 8 a 6 esto significa que
por cada 8 huevos tenemos 6 tazas de
harina pero si dijéramos que por cada 6
tazas de harina tenemos 8 huevos
entonces lo escribiríamos como 6 a 8 el
orden es muy importante aquí estamos
diciendo que la razón de huevos con
respecto a las tazas de harina es 8 a 6
por cada 8 huevos tenemos 6 tazas de
harina y que me dicen del pastel pequeño
aquí podemos ver que por cada 4 huevos 4
huevos tenemos 3 tazas de harina tenemos
3 tazas de harina entonces cuál sería la
razón por cada 4 huevos tenemos 3 tazas
de harina así que la razón entre los
huevos y las tazas de harina es 4 a 3
pero resulta que estas dos razones son
exactamente iguales porque miren si por
cada 8 huevos tenemos 6 tazas de harina
es la misma razón si decimos que por
cada 4 huevos tenemos 3 tazas de harina
porque lo único que hacemos es dividir
cada uno de esos números entre 2 podemos
decir que en cualquiera de los dos casos
la razón entre huevos y harina lo
escribiré la razón de huevos con
respecto a las tazas de harina
tazas de harina en cualquier caso es de
4 huevos por cada 3 tazas de harina y
esto es verdadero para cualquiera de
estas recetas porque tenemos la misma
razón o proporción miren aquí tenemos 8
huevos y si por cada 4 huevos
necesitamos 3 tazas de harina eso
significa que en este caso necesitamos 6
tazas de harina por eso es que las
razones también llamadas proporciones
son tan útiles esta receta tiene un
número diferente de huevos de tazas de
harina diferente número de tazas de
azúcar pero las razones entre los
ingredientes son iguales con lo que
podremos hacer un pastel que sabrá
exactamente igual porque básicamente es
el mismo pastel pero de un tamaño
diferente nos vemos en otro vídeo